hey youtubers is charlie so a lots been
going on with the Walking Dead this
summer so I thought it was time to do a
bonus video they've actually been
filming season 5 so we've gotten a
pretty good look at some of the new
characters and the cast have been doing
a lot of season five interviews teasing
a lot of the plot so this video is going
to be a breakdown of all that they're
also been some really big rumors about
supposed character death so i'll talk
about that too hello to all the new
people who are just finding me for the
first time because they're filming
season 5 right now i'm going to be doing
bonus videos until the premiere which is
going to be this fall be sure to
subscribe to get everything feel free to
grab some barbecue off the grill just do
not ask where we got it from so starting
off with new characters last week Seth
Gilliam was on set dressed as a priest
so I think it's safe to say he's playing
father Gabriel from the comics he was
announced a long time ago and he fit the
description of that character but now
he's basically been spotted we also saw
that infamous car that you liked Beth
onset recently it was that one with the
cross on the back the first time we saw
it that there is were all over the place
somewhere between hunters saviors could
have been father Gabriel now it looks
like it really was father Gabriel the
show changes stuff from the comic books
all the time so whenever she got
kidnapped and a lot of people were
thinking that it might be something from
the dáil story in the comics even though
we've learned not to trust you people I
don't think Gabriel is a bad person but
careful for spoilers for his backstory
from the comics real quick if you don't
want to know anything about Gabriel from
the comics just skip forward in the
video like 20 seconds so ready here we
go Gabriel had a church before the
outbreak where he was pretty normal
after [ __ ] hit the fan everyone in the
area started to come to him for food and
protection but because there was so many
he just started turning them away he was
afraid of running out of food and
supplies that's his tragic backstory
he's haunted by that failure so it's
possible that he took Beth to try and
atone for that to try and save her
there's been no indication that he's
going to be a terminus character at
least at the start of the season
supposedly he took Beth and went
somewhere else either Alexandria but
more likely i think his church the place
where Beth and Daryl were seemed more
like a funeral parlor that Gabriel's
church from the comics a couple of weeks
ago there was a picture taken of a set
where there was a church but it was a
completely different location so it
could be Gabriel's or it could be
completely random so far there's no
indication on the show how far Gabriel
is going to be from terminus just for
reference here it is on an actual map
it's in
terminus that is just to give you an
idea where the main characters are
that's not really where they film it
that's just where they are on the show
the actual terminus scenes where they
film in real life is pretty near the
location where they shot the pilot in
Atlanta Georgia aside from the confirmed
father Gabriel the other big new
character is named Burton enews revealed
that character description he's
basically a teenager like bets age and
he's going to be one of the other
captains of terminus he wasn't one of
the survivors one of the prison people
so obviously he's going to be someone
they've run into while they're at
terminus the character trait that's
being teased is that he only has what
leg no details on whether he lost it
before he arrived or after as it lost it
to the BBQ grill it sounds like they
might be giving part of Dale story from
the comics to burden because the
terminus cannibals are a little bit like
the hunters but they are completely
different characters in the comics
before dealt died he was bidden by
walkers then captured by the hunters
they ate one of his legs before he was
rescued by Rick of the survivors so it
could just be a coincidence or they
could be paying homage to that moment in
the comics with this Burton character
he's also supposedly going to be
spending a lot of time with Bob Stokey
which i think is interesting I feel like
Bob really needs some friends there were
a couple of new teenage characters in
season four like Patrick and Zach they
turned out to be total red shirts and
died pretty quick so we don't really
know what's going to happen with Burton
or if he's gonna be like a much bigger
part of the story I'm hoping he's not
going to turn out to be a red shirt I
would like to see some new cast members
brought onto the show we did get
Abraham's group last year which was
pretty cool one of the big running
themes with the main characters is
finding a reason to keep fighting I
think the major arc of season five is
going to be escaping from terminus and
the cannibals then season six is going
to be the road to Alexandria and season
7 will be BAM you know full-on negan
I've actually already done a negan video
for season five supposedly he's going to
make an appearance Scott Gimple and
Robert Kirkman have both been talking
about him a lot but the way they talk
about him kind of implies that he's not
going to be a main character until a
future season like not this Ethan he'll
be part of it but just a small part this
is where the Gareth character comes in
think of him as being a slightly
different version of the Chris character
from the comics the leader of the
hunters Gareth was upgraded to cast
regular for season five so he's going to
be in most of the episodes but no word
on whether or not he's going to survive
a season six but he's definitely not
going to be the new gov
if you ever watch the air this season
think of Gareth is being like the
brother blood character like the medium
bad someone who paves the way for
someone way worse to come along in this
case that person would be needed but
terminus is not in the comic so the
show's probably not going to introduce
negan until they get closer to
Alexandria so here's a couple of major
rumors about the main cast members and
they are just rumors so totally
unconfirmed but supposedly Maggie is
going to be pregnant and Glenn is going
to be the one to die so I have to talk
about Glenn from the comics real quick
so careful for spoilers for Glenn in the
comics just skip forward in the video
like 20 seconds if you don't want to
know so caramel ready there we go Glen
does die in the comics but he's killed
by negan who smashes the hell out of him
with Lucille his bad so if the show
kills Glenn at terminus it would be a
huge change the rumor started whenever a
lot of Masterson posted this really
ominous sounding tweak where she was
supposedly saying goodbye to certain
characters it's not confirmation but it
does imply that something really major
is going to happen to cleanse character
especially in the first couple of
episodes so here's also where I have to
talk a little bit about Maggie in the
comics so just skip forward like 20
seconds if you don't want spoilers from
the comics in the comics Maggie tried to
commit suicide after falling into a deep
depression remember how I said season
five is all about escaping terminus and
finding a reason to keep on fighting
well supposedly Maggie is contemplating
suicide after cleanse suppose a death
but it's her pregnancy cleanse unborn
baby that gives her the will to keep
living so it seems like babies are going
to be a sign of hope in season 5
speaking of which let's talk about baby
Judith she is still with Carol Tyrese
who are not at terminus yet but it seems
like they're going to get there
eventually because Norman Reedus was
talking about his relationship with
Carol in the comics they did have a
thing but the show hasn't really done
that so eventually it sounds like we're
going to see a lot of them together this
season Norman Reedus said that Darrell
sees a lot of himself in her so don't
expect any hardcore sex scenes but it
sounds like the show is slowly heading
in the carrel darrell direction once all
this seeks in let me know what you think
about the idea of father Gabriel being
on the show and being a good character
as well as Glen dying and Maggie being
pregnant those are some big rumors but
mostly I'm just looking forward to
seeing the first trailer for season 5
that's actually going to be one of my
next Walking Dead videos going to be
about or at least it's going to be about
the special marathon where they're going
to debut new footage AMC is just doing a
special fourth of July
I walking dead marathon with her
basically airing everything from Season
one to season four back to back at the
end of that on july six they're doing a
special talking dead episode where
they're going to premiere some footage
from season five so i'm going to do a
full breakdown of that be sure to
subscribe to get my video i'm going to
do a couple bonus videos before that
though in the meantime click here to
learn about negan in season five and
click here for some of my other season 5
predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives